and today I thought we'd talk about a
specific strategy you can use when
you're making a decision about which
move you should make in any given
position in a chess game and the theme
of tonight is going to be elimination
now sometimes when you're playing chess
and you're thinking about what move to
make you might come up with several
candidate moves you I could play move a
b c d and usually you just start and you
think about okay this move looks good
because i don't know it takes something
or because it does something and you
look at the merit of the move and you're
like okay and you only focus on what's
good about it for you
but sometimes you can eliminate choices
just using the process of elimination by
finding moves that are just wrong or you
can find a problem with the move and
then you can just eliminate it so if you
have four moves and move C and D both
like get you made it and the next move
then you just eliminate C D you don't
have to look at them anymore and then
you might be thinking all right I got
choice a I got choice B and okay choice
a you start calculating oh it's deep
over here here he has a resource I have
a resource there's this sacrifice it's
really really confusing and then you
think about B for a second and you go oh
wait a minute if I do B I just lose a
piece well you don't have to consider
anything more you just play move a
because otherwise you know you know the
result of the other three and so by
elimination you can find the right move
so going over to the board here we have
a position that was reached between
Garry Kasparov and Alexi sheriff in
Estonia 2001 and the good news is the
audience was able to tell whose turn it
is in this position before the class so
we got that back going for us it is
black to move notice that you are in
check and okay before we really get
started I guess I'll just ask how many
legal moves does black have yeah five
right so we can go to any one of these
squares and so you want to kind of go
through sometimes it's like oh five
that's you know a ton but some of them
can just be ruled out with you know a
second or two of calculation so for
starters I guess in at home you can you
can pause if you want a little bit more
time that's worth thinking about it the
class has had ten minutes to think about
this puzzle already is there is there
any move that's just really easy to
eliminate there's no real need to
calculate okay and well we'll start
we'll start a little slower she she
figured it out cuz again they've had
more time okay going to the H file any
any move on the H file is really easy to
eliminate because what will white play
rook H one yeah rook d2 yeah the point
is this rook is already perfect you know
all you have to do now is attack the H
file so rook d2 and you swing over and
you have the GNH file and you give
checkmate you don't want to check
because then the king will run back to
safety but with that in mind I mean okay
so already that's sixty percent of the
moves just easily discarded so really
there's only two possible moves that we
should even consider and okay so again
in general people are you like to think
about you know what's really good about
the position what a certain move does to
improve your position but is there a
move that anyone other than iris can
rule out by elimination so you are
looking to refute like your own move so
in a way elimination is sort of
prophylactic thinking because you're
thinking okay if I gave the move back to
my opponent you know if I make this move
and it's his turn what is he gonna play
and by thinking this way you can you can
sort of find trying to find a Fault in
the moves rather than just thinking
about what's what's good about it for
you so is there anybody else in the
class that can find a fault with one of
these two moves either King f5 or king
f7
I was there only one person like just
can't wait can't wait she can't wait to
answer just you're saying if here yeah
and also we could take on that for two
if we if we wanted to mmm alright in the
back but which one can you eliminate
excellent and so this was actually
played in the game so okay in this game
this was a mistake
and yes she said just rook d4 and the
black king gets mated so I don't really
know what he was thinking I assume this
is one of those moves to where it seems
like you know that's that seems like a
good move your kings getting active
you're attacking upon and perhaps he was
just expecting you know some move like
this sir who knows what he was expecting
but I'm sure Rick d4 was just a big
surprise because you're just powerless
the king is getting trapped and you're
getting mated so and I think yeah if
you're just thinking about what white
wants to play and I guess he must not
have he must just have miscalculated he
just simply didn't see rook d4 because
now the game's over on the other hand I
mean okay we've we've eliminated these
moves they all get made it so in a
certain sense it doesn't matter what the
evaluation is after king f7 you're not
getting mated immediately
so okay and white is probably a little
bit better but it's still a game and it
doesn't actually really matter the whole
point of this lecture is you can just
eliminate certain moves and then you
play the only other move that doesn't
either immediately lose or immediately
get checkmate it or lose a bunch of
material or something
so here black just has to play King f7
and okay the game continues you don't
have to resign so okay so that was that
was just a simple case for at least one
person
we'll take a look at another game this
is Fabiano Cara wanna versus live EU DD
or Nyssa piano from 2012 and we'll get
well watch a couple of games here a
couple moves here just to get an idea of
the theme I thought you read some
tournament don't you like World Open
national Philadelphia something it's
over already how'd you do you failed so
here we are
Cara wanna miss a piano we'll watch a
few moves here just to get a good feel
for this game and an interesting
exchange sacrifice it wasn't totally
necessary but it's interesting and in
the position like this and what black
had been counting on was this move but
this is actually a miscalculation
so after here I assumed he figured that
he has a perpetual which is the only way
reason that black would play this way
so we'll go a few more moves so we can
get sort of a feeling if King f1 then
there just is a perpetual so to make
progress White has to move up the board
and now Queen to c1 so ok white is
trying to escape the checks for the
moment why does it rook up but the rook
on a4 is loose so you know sometimes we
can check and win the rook and even in
this position black already had the
opportunity if you wanted to but King
III Queen c1 and we'll pause now and
again I'll ask the first question is how
many legal moves does white have in this
position alright some people say - some
people say 3
some people say 2 and then 3 it's either
2 or 3 it's - some people see - some
people see 3 I see 3 it's just me so now
that we've got the tough question out of
the way so some moves usually are easier
to eliminate than others yeah
he said the answer well you know right
why would you listen to that guy you
this is the guy you're gonna listen to
well that's right all right good job for
example to help out the class okay if
you play a move like King you too well
now we're just repeating so something
like this is easy you're gonna have to
go up to make progress in this position
so okay King you two it should just be a
draw so the real question is should you
take or should you go to d4 and so for
this again you want to pause at home
because I'm gonna give them a minute
here to think about it and again don't
think about you know why you want to
play something because it's good for you
you want to say if I play here what are
they gonna play and if you can find for
example that black hasn't perpetual then
that move is probably not not right or
at least you'd be doing doing well to
try the other move okay so it's it's
White's to move because you're in check
if you go back to e2 we've we've ruled
it out as a draw and so the question is
should we take on e4 or shall we play
King d4 and the real question is how do
you escape their perpetual as white
and I'm not calling on you right I might
call on him maybe he's seen the game
and again we're trying to eliminate
possibilities so if in one variation you
can find it perpetual well then you can
just eliminate that and focus on the
other one yeah I'll call any affined
king e4 does what to Queen c2 this was
played in the game but black did not
play Queen c2
but I can actually do better black now
has a perpetual and this was played in
the game so it's not about getting the
rook because of white still gonna be up
a bunch of pawns and you know making
progress it's about the perpetual do you
see it mmm-hmm right yeah either way and
black even in this position could have
taken the rook but I he's not interested
in the rook he's interested in finding a
perpetual so if you you take its check
and if you take here as was played in
the game can anyone find the perpetual
or do we have to call on our all-star
back there you're not here okay good
good queenie III queenie one yeah and
this was played in the game and yeah
this just is a perpetual one problem is
if you you know try to run this other
way we can go here and okay you have to
go to a position like this but now we
check here you have to stay where your
queen is and we can do this so no matter
what its gonna be a perpetual and this
is actually what what happened in the
game sorry this their repeated how did
they actually repeat this is how they
decided to repeat in the game okay and
then it was a draw so okay by
elimination if we see that and again if
you have to kind of not be preoccupied
about the rook cuz okay he might get the
rook anyway but you need to escape the
perpetual if you want to try to play for
the win as white so if you see that this
is a perpetual and you see that this
also is the same by elimination the only
move to really try to play for a win is
king to d4 and so this wasn't played but
white actually would get a winning
position after this check if the King
just runs to the Queen side so in a
position like this he can run to the
Queen side and start attacking the base
of this pawn chain maybe make some
passers and it's white that is thinking
about winning in this
and again it comes I mean I assume in
the game if you're just thinking well
what the merits of this move is I take
upon so that's that's good but the fault
is you get perpetual so you're the only
way to escape is is to play the move
king d4 and if this had happened then
Caruana
probably would have gone on to win this
game okay now we'll do a famous example
that some people might be aware of this
is the game between a nun's and Carlsen
from a rather important tournament a
world championship
it was round nine and we got a very
exciting game where black is going and
making a queen and white allows it and
just goes right for an attack and okay
Carlson's sort of defending against some
of the threats and in this position the
very aggressive move rook to f4 was
played which obviously allows black to
make a queen but White's thinking re I'm
just gonna go checkmate you so a very
exciting position and this again is sort
of one of like the most important
decisions that's ever been made in chess
this is a world championship game and
this game is this decision that was made
on this very next move determined who
was gonna win and become the world
champion so here are nuns blundered
again I'll ask the hopefully easy
question how many legal moves does
weight have that many four four four all
right isn't this one like trickier than
the other one but but everybody found it
right there's four legal moves you can
block with three different pieces or you
can play king f2 and okay to rule some
out the only way you're gonna get
compensation for the fact that you let
black get a queen is if the rook goes
over here and you check me you know
that's what you're you're hoping for
because black obviously is up a lot of
material so rook f1 is pretty easy to
eliminate because even if you just took
the rook you'd still be winning
but you wouldn't need to to be that
drastic so this one it's pretty easy to
rule out this this guy has a very clear
purpose in life and just to give you
another hint okay if a move like this we
can we can rule this out so even if in a
position like this if you block black
can always afford to give stuff back pin
the rook which would prevent you from
going over here so this is the kind of
thing that black is hoping to do you
know give the Queen away to get some
material and avoid getting checkmated so
the two main moves are blocking on f1
either with the knight or the bishop and
I'll give you guys a minute at home you
can pause and take as much time as you
need and and again so one of these moves
is like really really complicated and
you can calculate all the super
complications or you can think about
refuting one of the moves and then you
only need to see one or two moves just
to rule it out and know that you have to
play the other move so I leave it to the
class so the real question is which move
can you eliminate so if you can refute
one of the moves and it's either the
other move or they both lose yes and
this is the game and here resigns and
Carlson won the game and yet to
illustrate the point he said if the rook
goes here made the very big threat we
take it so this is just for signs and
Carlson went on to win the championship
so that's very good and that's just by
thinking of it in the simplest way
that's how you do it perhaps he was
thinking only of a move like this and
here but okay even after some really
complicated stuff that you didn't really
need to see to get this puzzle right
what white white wins but well yeah
that's exactly the way to solve this
puzzle this move loses because I can go
here and prevent you
going here because I just take it or you
could have done it the hard way and set
set here and calculated this and then
realized you get this crazy position and
okay then there's there yet to calculate
this move and g 6x clam and all these
moves and the sacrifice and all that you
could have calculated all of that and
then like okay that's why this is this
is a draw or you could have just ruled
one out because it just loses on the
spot so we're turning one more time
queenie one just prevents your next move
and the game is over so it's just by
using elimination you can arrive much
quicker sometimes at a conclusion and i
don't know it's probably fatigue gets
game nine the games are long so there's
just an oversight here cuz rook f4
actually was a decent attempt but okay
he just he didn't quite follow it up
right or saw a ghost or something
but okay that's a we got one more let's
do one more this is a game between Peter
Svidler and Veselin Topalov from 2006
Linares will give you a couple moves
here so a very interesting position in
which white gives up a rook with the
hope of making a queen and okay so in
this position we start to think for
white and this will be our final example
here for the night so I'll start with
the sometimes easy sometimes hard
question how many legal moves does white
have okay so we got we have five five
okay so some are easier to rule out than
others and one important feature of this
position is if black can just take this
so in any variation where I play here
let's draw a funny arrow and you have to
take back black will win cuz the King
runs in and munches up the beep on so we
know that we need to keep the pawn on
the board we need to be able to make a
queen
if you can ever sacrifice then the roof
of the pond then we can eliminate that
variation on the spot so I don't want to
know what the move is but who can
eliminate any of the moves okay tell me
one right so yeah if you go up in either
way that the result is the same we
pinned the pond so now you can't make it
clean and no matter what you do we can
at least take you know if you go here we
can we can take it and then the black
King runs in and eats the pawns so very
good that leaves us with just three
moves so it's very simple
yep two are gone any others we can
eliminate right correct
King c5 King f5 rook e1 exactly so even
if you Queen I can skewer you and pick
up the Queen which so by elimination
there's only one move you can play and
that's King to g5 okay and now it's very
similar again after this check I mean
going up we repeat you know again if you
go too far away from the pond I could
just get right behind it if you go here
then I play rook e1 so okay so again
here and it's it's interesting because
you actually you have two choices now
and actually both of these moves are
playable so I will I will ask so we'll
see if we can we can eliminate any one
of these so it's a little bit tougher
and it isn't particularly pertinent to
the problems so I mean just continuing
the pattern is I think what most most
people would do King f3 is playable with
the idea that after rook e1 you can play
King F 2 so the rook doesn't get behind
the King but it does allow this
variation so even seeing this makes you
realize well if I don't pull if I just
play my king to g3 you don't take my
pawn with check okay so we do this again
and okay so it's looking very good for
white but black still has some tricks
here so a very clever move a3 and I'll
give you guys three options you can take
take or promote and two of them actually
work in this case but we'll see you can
you eliminate one of them there's one
that just just doesn't work
so we can just avoid thinking about it
for too long yeah
yeah if he takes the rook you Queen - so
we can get a position like this where we
both queen and white can check for a
long time but you're not gonna be able
to win this position so this would be a
draw so that was pretty easy to
eliminate so you have two choices and in
the game he decided to Queen which is
probably the most accurate move but it
requires a lots of calculation here is
also a safe choice but again if he goes
and gets these guys you have to play the
move a four you don't want to Queen and
let him take your pawn but after a four
and you queen he's not gonna take this
because you skewer and wind stuff so
this was playable but in the game he
decided to make a queen and black
actually could have made a very
difficult move for white to face or at
least set up one little trap that's very
very difficult to see in the game he
took here but more complicated is a two
so we'll look at this first and we'll
come back to the game and now the task
for white is to go get this pawn if you
can just play pawn you know Queen takes
pawn then and I always draw the arrows
because I know you love them if they're
like illegal arrows that's so the plate
is you have to go get that pawn because
he's gonna Queen too so you don't have
time to take the rook
for example because black makes a queen
so I'll offer you two possible routes
the white might take and then I will
give you a lot of time because
eliminating one is very very difficult
so I'll be really impressed if anybody
is able to figure out why one of these
answers is wrong well you can check from
here obviously we can't skewer you
because of the rook so that's been
illuminated but we can check and then
weasel around and get the Queen on this
side of the pond so we can get the Queen
to the a file we can use you know a
variety of different checks but in any
ways we should be able to get to the a
file or as an alternative we can check
this way and take the long way over and
pick up the pawn via that route so
you're going to go over the top or
around
to the bottom how are you gonna get
there to the pond
that's the the task and at home you can
you can pause and if anyone here
actually can eliminate one of these
plans a major major congrats to anyone
solve the hardest puzzle ever yeah maybe
did you eliminate one of them okay which
one you think works out okay then Queen
to h6 and and you're gonna go over the
mountain and through the woods
okay but does anybody see what uh what
blacks super saving resource is anybody
know this is actually a mistake by white
a four and if you take looking black
play here
yeah Brooke h1 excellent and remarkably
this is a fortress the black queen can't
move and so I'm sorry the White Queen
cannot move so you actually can't make
significant progress here as white which
is just I mean it's amazing the queen is
just trapped in out of the game
so you can't win this as white really
play around with it yep you get play
around with it so you're in this so back
in this line so now you're gonna switch
you're gonna switch and go the other way
you go check on b3 yeah yeah so amazing
so yeah if at home you are able to
eliminate that variation because you're
like oh yeah fortress got it you know
okay so that that wasn't either player's
calculation but if on a - you decide to
check and and come the shorter route
okay there's a couple different
variations but just to illustrate the
point in a position like this well
you're close to trapping the Queen you
have one tempo to save her and you
escape so so yeah if you saw that at
home then you know you're genius which
is why all the comments would be like
yes all that easy that's what they
usually are you know it's like you know
the easi easiest puzzle I've ever seen
in my life
in the game however after queening he
took on a2 and it's still not the
easiest thing in the world to do for for
white to win here because there's
there's still lots of tricks so again
King b5 and there's gonna be all sorts
of little tiny tricks here so
like stalemate so if anyone can find a
stalemate and I'll give you okay we can
take the pawn we can take the rook so
it's basically two moves to consider
we're gonna take something so if you can
find a move that would lead to stalemate
then okay that's easy to eliminate so
yeah what-what can you eliminate after
rookie two are you sure because you
think I'm gonna take this way but it's
the right idea
f3 exactly and yeah as long as I run
this way you just keep checking me along
the third-ranked and as soon as I I go
this this way you check here and okay
this would be still me so just okay
based on that it's easy to eliminate one
move so King takes okay and again you
have to be careful you can approach with
the King or approach with the Queen and
again if you can find one that leads to
stalemate you can eliminate it
anyone see a move we can eliminate yeah
which one
mm-hmm so yeah if we approach again
Queen right exactly and you have to
Queen nothing else then however you take
back it's a stalemate
so okay for that reason we we can't
approach with the king and here white
okay it's these are the types of
positions that are usually you know very
difficult to win but Lloyd showed
perfect technique and understanding of
this position I took like all the stuff
and you know a couple more checks and
some very accurate moves comes all the
way around the horn and here black
resigned seeing the oncoming checkmate
the game could have continued like this
and after the check you only have to
find one more move here as white you can
pause but I'm just going to give it away
Queen to see three threatening checkmate
I've one last trick ah-ha-ah-ha
but okay after Queen B - it's actually
these unclean because okay if you move
over I can go here if you move the
knight then I get access to d2 so the
game ended right here so unfortunately
we don't have time to go over a viewer
game today I might start doing them as
part of like the one-minute series
because that way I'll be able to get a
lot more of them in because we so often
run out of time here but uh okay now
hopefully I gives you another tool a
thinking tool that you can use when
you're making decisions at the
chessboard if you can eliminate moves
based on the flaws and faults that they
contain then you can easily weed out
some moves that without a whole bunch of
calculation and you can be like you lose
you lose you lose you don't lose you
play the don't lose move hopefully that
helps a little bit and if you like this
video hit like share subscribe and I'll
see you guys next week
you